[Music]
hey
we're back once again yeah and you guys
are here again too because you're not
sick of us yet
yeah once today it's wednesday some
reason i lost my connection oh [ __ ] look
what happened
you got it you got it just make sure
that make sure the uh what you call it
the volumes turn down so it doesn't like
distract me over there so yeah here's my
internet
here in florida oh [ __ ] look at that i
don't know how that yeah
hopefully we're still on are we
i guess yeah i guess yeah it looks like
nobody says we're not
okay all right otherwise we could be
talking to nobody right now and we don't
even know about it
so yeah here we are in florida it was
again it was really cold this morning
when i went out to
go for a walk the [ __ ] that was frost
all over the grass cold for florida what
50
40 degrees yeah well yesterday morning
it was 43
and this morning it was actually like it
felt colder to me
so it must have been upper 30s maybe
yeah um so you know crazy and right now
i just checked my phone like
two minutes ago and it's only 54 degrees
outside all right so
enough enough of the weather enough for
the weather we got movies to do jenny
has a jacket on yeah i did yesterday too
yeah we saw a gemini man finally yeah i
saw gemini man he saw amazon yeah gemini
man
gemini man we were seeing trailers for
it right around the time the [ __ ]
pandemic hit and then
no actually it was earlier than that
because i thought that too but then when
i looked it up on wikipedia this movie
actually came out last october
october 2019. why didn't we see it this
would have been something we would have
seen
we just never got around to it i guess i
don't know i'm not buying that
no that's when it came out october
running out of movies to watch
there towards the end i don't think
maybe it ever maybe it never came out in
our theater
yeah it did it did yeah i remember
seeing the poster never saw just for
some reason we never got around to
seeing
it but yeah i thought that too i thought
it came out at the beginning of this
year but it was actually like the end of
last year or you know it was like
late october last year yeah 2019. yeah
jim and i man
was uh the will smith movie and
um it's like a spy movie
yeah i'd probably put it on par with
like a mission impossible
movie uh cross team mission impossible
and
a james bond movie um
now i it wasn't quite as [ __ ]
action and stunt pat stunt packed as
say mission impossible and it didn't
quite
seem as [ __ ] high-end as a james bond
movie
but it was pretty good actually it
actually was not as bad as i was
expecting it to be
well because i didn't really know i
remember seeing
like they had trailers for this every
time we went to the movies last year
there was just like trailers and
trailers and trailers
and then we just never ended up seeing
it and then i didn't really hear a lot
about it other than people it seemed
like most of the reviews were like
meh you know what i mean yeah um and it
ended up like it said it was like a big
bomb but the thing about it is that
it made 173 million dollars but it cost
138 million dollars to make yes so
that's still like a failure because
yeah you need to make at least like
twice the production budget back to uh
to break even uh because of the
marketing costs and all that other kind
of [ __ ]
so it didn't do as well as they expected
it to yeah
the acting was pretty good story was
good uh
had it took you to [ __ ] interesting
locations kind of like a bond flick does
took you to uh budapest took you to
hungary
it took you to uh uh what was the other
one um columbia
oh yeah cartagena yeah and then it was
just like romancing the stone the only
other movie that i can think of that was
again
and they uh you know the the the
interiors
were good you know looking high-tech
[ __ ] offices and [ __ ]
it's about will smith he's he's
basically like an ex-marine corps
guy who's working for some kind of an
intelligence agency
they never really didn't name it did
they they just had him going out [ __ ]
killing people yeah he was just
like a sniper and uh
he he's starting to like you know he's
got 73 kills he's getting sick of it he
doesn't really like it you know he
didn't really have a family
life or anything and uh it's just kind
of his conscience is starting to [ __ ]
with him about it
turns out he's finding out that some of
these people that he killed were totally
innocent
it's just that the agencies wanted them
dead for political so they made up a
bunch of [ __ ] about him and
he didn't know that this was happening
but behind his back you know they
uh they had the ability to clone people
they made a clone of him
and they got he's got a young version of
himself
running around well they send the young
clone after him to kill him to get him
out of the way
so he meets his own clone um
and then that's where that's where the
fun begins there's really only two
things i could see that was that was
wrong with this movie but
they weren't deal breakers there's a
motorcycle chase scene
where being a writer myself obviously
it's obvious that
some a lot of [ __ ] was cg and the cg
wasn't that great
nope it would have been better for them
to actually
tone the motorcycle scene down and do it
all live action
you'd have like jory and ponarev or
something do it he could do some of
those stunts have jory and do that [ __ ]
and uh and probably be cheaper than
[ __ ]
probably been cheaper to hire joria to
do it than to have uh
cg do it the cg wasn't totally
convincing um
i'd rather see tom cruise actually
really do it on his motorcycle like in
[ __ ]
um what is mission impossible a lot of
that [ __ ] you see tom cruise did it
looks like he really did it
and he could ride so i don't i don't
think that's really him reckon
because he's he wrecked a lot well yeah
because it would cost too much to ensure
to assure him they need a stunt man to
do but yeah you can tell that
out of that last that last um
[ __ ] an impossible flick man you you
could tell those are that was real
motorcycle stunts
now the second thing that's kind of
bothered me about this movie
is that when you first see um the clown
the first time you see the clone they
show it for too long and you start
getting that uncanny
valley you know that it's not
a real person just the way it moves
you know well it's just not a real
person and they shouldn't have done that
what they did the thing about this movie
it's
like i said it's not like a great movie
but it was like
fun it was fun um like i said i was kind
of expecting it to suck out loud and it
didn't suck as much as i thought
one thing and zach just mentioned this
in the comments
this was directed by ang lee obviously
you did like the incredible hulk movie
did broke back mountain needed life of
pie he did like see he's done
like some really good movies and um even
though i kind of want to go into like
the
production history of this because this
goes back like way farther than maybe
most people realize
but one thing that they did was he shot
it
in 120 frames per second
which uh if you're not familiar with
movie making the standard i believe is
24 frames per second
so he filmed it in this really fast
frame and then like the there are no
theaters in the country or there's only
like a couple of theaters in the country
that could actually
show it like that so you didn't really
get the experience that the director
wanted and when you see it like in
hd or whatever it looks a little weird
like it looks a little
flat i guess because everything is in
focus or like in the same focus so it
looked a little strange
that didn't really bother me that much
you know what bothered me i don't even
know if i've never
seen anyone else mention this it sounded
like
everybody's dialogue was adr'd
maybe it means it was like it was done
in post okay yeah
and i'm not sure if they did or either
that or like the
the sound mix was strange it was just i
couldn't really put my finger on it it
just sounded like to me it sounded like
the dialogue was like too loud or it was
like two i don't know it was like
something that was really bothering me
like i didn't notice it
yeah it's like maybe it's just me i
don't know but it's like that was just
something really bad but the thing they
did with the
with the motion capture like with will
smith's face
the thing about it is that that is will
smith's young
face because obviously there's a lot of
footage of will smith from
when he was 23 years old because he's
been acting like forever
so they basically like digitally
composited like
shots of his actual 23 year old face
like onto his actual
like body it was it looked fake but yeah
it still
looked strange like they couldn't get it
wasn't bad
um but it still looked a little you knew
that that wasn't
a real person like it seemed like his
lips were too
were pursing too much or like when he
talked and stuff it was a little weird
and i had to kind of like look away from
it a little bit because it was like
distracting
another thing too that was like um
because will smith
they you know they make a lot of jokes
about him being 51 years old in this so
i guess that was like a red run as a
real age like when he shot it
he doesn't look they you know they make
all these jokes about him being like all
old and everything like that and yeah 51
i guess is old for an assassin but he
doesn't look that
old so it's like so it was another you
know it'd be one thing if he was like
just this old
grizzled like gray-haired you know
codger
no he's still in but he's still he's
still in really good shape he's still
like climbing or running around and he's
still he's not wrinkly
or anything like that he has like a
little bit of gray right here and that's
about it
so it's just it was kind of funny like
to see his 23 year old self going old
man what's up
they really don't look them like far
apart at age at least the least of me
they don't yeah and if you look at 23
year old will smith
next to [ __ ] 51 year old will smith
50 once will
51 year old will smith beat the [ __ ] out
of that guy
i mean i could say for myself you know
as a young soldier
at 20 in my early 20s 23 i could run
all day and run all night and just
[ __ ] didn't need much recovery
you could just when you're young you
they can just run the [ __ ] out of you
you know but because we didn't have a
whole lot of time in the army to [ __ ]
work out and recover and gain muscle
mass and you weren't eating enough
and sleeping enough you didn't really
get massive
and the guys that did looking back on it
they were juicing oh yeah
yeah but back then we didn't really
think that way
and how i am now if i were to go back in
time and meet my [ __ ] 20
23 year old self the young me would be
able to outrun me
it could probably outlast me in terms of
endurance you know what i mean
but i could beat that i could beat my
young self up
i'd beat the [ __ ] out of myself here's
another shirt i'm gonna have like a
picture of young tom like with his
feathered hair
like this rick springfield hair and like
a picture of you now it's like my old
self complete my young self
i could beat my own yeah just in terms
of just raw strength i'm at least twice
as strong
now i my young self would just run and
get me tired yeah
and run rings right you know until i got
tired and then try to come in yeah your
young self but i would just run
away from me i would just wrestle my
young self and just [ __ ]
pass my young son give me nookie and
[ __ ] and [ __ ]
i'd treat my young self like a [ __ ]
i'll get a hold of my younger self i
think that's just fine
no i'm just trying to i'm just like
imagining it
because i've seen pictures of you yeah i
didn't know you back then but i've seen
pictures of it
nowadays i can bench press nearly 300
pounds
[Laughter]
back in those days i'd be lucky to bench
about 160
170. yeah yeah i do [ __ ] 200 i
i do [ __ ] 200 pounds i do 10 reps of
that and do
to 10 sets of that within a [ __ ]
about a half hour or so yeah
you know i couldn't do that when i was
[ __ ] young that was too weak
it takes time yeah you were like a
smaller
smaller yeah smaller frame back then
yeah now you jump on some gear
and start lifting yeah you'll grow big
quickly
but it's just that's not the lifestyle i
had back then yeah
yeah and in the army everything was
about running and endurance
i could say and trying to do without
food and sleep
well because that's like more important
more important your missions might be
you know it might entail
because it's all just [ __ ] hiking and
walking right exactly it's all [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that
yeah light infantry so and then
big guys that we had that went through
basic didn't make it they didn't have
the endurance
your heart has to pump a lot of [ __ ]
blood to all that muscle tissue
and then you need to [ __ ] have a
certain caloric intake constantly to
keep all that muscle running
and you might be able to do it for a
[ __ ] three or four days but we're
gonna we're talking about three or four
weeks
for a mission yeah you know you're not
getting much sleep you're just
massive guys well you told me that like
sometimes you would just be marching all
night and you'd just be sleeping while
you were watching while you're walking
[Laughter]
sleep walking and [ __ ] yeah drive you
crazy
yeah that's why and that's why a lot of
people don't understand
and predator one when [ __ ] um
oh what blaine says is some badass bush
boy you'd lose it out here you could
lose it out here
if you lost it out here you'd be a in a
world of hurt
and some people don't know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about if you're
fighting okay imagine a truck driver
would understand it
if you're driving in a [ __ ] truck for
days upon days upon days you know not
getting a whole lot of sleep
especially back then the way truckers
used to
run themselves you know they you'd get
white line fever
where you kind of lose your mind you
just seen that dotted line well [ __ ] man
i was like one time in my life like i
was
up for 48 hours straight like going to a
concert at a party and some other [ __ ]
and you know we drank not a lot but a
little bit in 48 hours even after just
48 hours
i started to hallucinate yeah so it
doesn't take all that like i was seeing
trains going across the highway and [ __ ]
like that
imagine you're walking in a ranger file
in dense
bush okay pouring down rain it's [ __ ]
hot and tropical and it's been doing
this [ __ ] for [ __ ] weeks
all right and you're fighting limbs
hitting you in the face and it's
and you're walking through the day and
the night maybe you're sleeping two or
three hours a day
you could lose your [ __ ] mind just
because you're getting hit by wet bushes
over and over and over again and there's
no escape yeah anything that happens
like that just keeps even if it's just
like a little annoyance but if it just
keeps doing it it's gonna drive you
crazy and all you're doing is
looking at the guy in front of you
because that's all you can see is the
dude walking in front of you and the
little cat eyes little glowing cat eyes
on the back of his helmet or his [ __ ]
ranger cap or whatever
and at night all you do is you see these
little pieces of glowing tape from
on the taped onto the you know it's like
it's sewn into the [ __ ]
yeah this guy's not in front of you and
you just see two [ __ ]
we call them cat eyes and that's kind of
like you know the tail lights for the
guy in front of you
you know just drive you [ __ ] crazy
and that's like it's why blaine says you
lost it out here you'd be in a world of
hurt yeah because
you start going into a mental tail spin
i've seen guys just [ __ ] lose it you
gotta
chill them out and [ __ ] try to but
like i said it's pretty understandable
but sometimes you're in a [ __ ]
company [ __ ] formation there's 100
guys you got to keep walking
there's no stopping yeah you know so you
just kind of
talk the guy down you know bad times
yeah but yeah so the interesting thing
that i well i found this interesting the
interesting thing about gemiini man to
me
is that this [ __ ] script has been
kicking around in hollywood since 1997.
they've been disney had it they actually
uh had optioned the script first
in 1997 and they were gonna make it and
tony scott was gonna direct it
and they um they had they hired like a
special effects lab like to do all the
face motion capture because like that
was the you know the thing it's been the
script's been rewritten a bunch of times
since then obviously
but the you know core idea of being
stalked by a clone of your younger self
that was still in there
so they did like all these tests and
stuff like that but they just said well
the technology is just not good enough
like back in 1997
so they tried it out a bunch of times
and they just couldn't like get it to
look good so they just shelved it but
interestingly listen to this [ __ ]
list of actors
that were attached to this project going
back to 1997. listen to this [ __ ]
harrison ford robert de niro al pacino
michael douglas chris o'donnell
mel gibson tommy lee jones kevin costner
pierce brosnan bruce willis
john travolta john voigt denzel
washington johnny depp nicholas cage
brad pitt keanu reeves tom cruise clint
eastwood
gerard butler nick nolte matt damon ben
affleck
jason statham dwayne johnson michael b
jordan idris elba arnold schwarzenegger
sylvester stallone and sean connery
all of which were attached to this
project
at one time or another but like i said
they just
they the reason that it got scrapped
largely was just because the
the technology wasn't there and disney
was like well we can't
you know we can't make it look realistic
and so we just don't want to do it so
then eventually
it kind of changed hands a bunch of
times and that sky dance bought it in
2016
and they started working toward but like
i said it went through like a bunch of
even different directors and
[ __ ] like that and actors and stuff
before they even got to this point
so it's amazing that this [ __ ] even got
made and yeah it did end up losing 111
million dollars
damn because it costs well it's like i
said it made 173 million but it cost so
much to make that
it's not a bad movie it's a good movie
uh it's a fun watch
it's not perfect but the things that are
wrong with it they're just
they're forgivable it's not a bad movie
it's about like it's about like uh
it's like a cross between a james bond
movie and a and uh um
and what's mission mission impossible i
put it about it like a mission
impossible
yeah not quite as i mean like you said
it was like a lower rent version of that
yeah not like mission impossible and uh
there should have been more benedict
wong in this i feel like he should have
been in it more
do you know where you know him from what
i know from prometheus prometheus he was
in prometheus
because like we've saw him around like
god damn it what the [ __ ] was that he's
been in other things too
um but that's the movie that because
we've seen prometheus a bunch of times
and i was like that's where i recognize
the only thing that that makes this not
quite measure up
to a mission impossible flick is that
you can tell that some of the stunts are
cg
if they were all kind of like in-camera
[ __ ] live-action
motorcycle stunts then i'd put it at the
same as
as mentioned impossible it's about like
a mission impossible
another criticism i had too is that a
lot of the fight scenes were in the dark
i couldn't tell what was going on yeah
but it wasn't that bad
yeah i mean like like i said i was not i
didn't really have any expectations like
i said
down in the catacombs yeah yeah yeah
it's like that was kind of cool but it's
like i couldn't really tell what was
going on that was on par with the james
bond
scene though a lot of this [ __ ] is like
you could tell they were lifting things
from the new james bond
series like the tone of a lot of it is
from the new james bond the color
palettes
and just the locations it felt like i
was on a james bond flick where i'm
going around the world
i did like that part of it the only
thing i didn't like about it is that the
the cg wasn't convincing all the time
sometimes it was better than others did
you notice that yeah
it was only a couple scenes where they
zoomed in on his face and showed his
face for too long the rest of it he's
moving around so much you don't really
see his face
but um they shouldn't have done that and
that's when they're first
introduced to the damn uh the clone when
they introduced the clone they showed it
for too long
yeah that was the problem it yeah it
just did look it looked
good it looked good it didn't look right
not right
and uh and then i would have done the uh
i would have simplified the motorcycle
chase scene and done it all
live action because there was once there
was a couple seconds in that motorcycle
chase where like the motorcycle was
going up like that in the writer and it
looked like a doll or it looked like you
know what i mean you know how it
you know how when they do cgi and not
quite right in the motion it's just like
too fast
too fast and your eye just picks it up
like oh that doesn't look like a rope
the motorcycles were doing things that
don't happen it's because
the motorcycles weren't obeying certain
physics the skids didn't look right
you know what i mean [ __ ] uh certain
angles of attack that the moment when
the motorcycle's leaned over and doing
stuff
you know as a rider there's just there's
a certain rhythm and a certain
feel to high action riding you know what
another guy could do because you've been
in this
in that position it takes time for
things to happen on a motorcycle
yeah you know what i mean and some of
that [ __ ] happens too fast you can't
flick a motorcycle over that fast
i think there's so much mass there i
think that's kind of why
like a lot of the early uh marvel movies
and stuff like that not so much the new
ones but
i think a lot of movies that are like
superhero movies or that re
rely on a lot of cgi um but that are
supposed to be
people like some of the early spider-man
movies and stuff like that
it's like they never get the physics
quite right it's like every
nothing everything looks like it doesn't
weigh anything yeah
you know what i mean it's exactly what
it looks like and it's like it's just
your eye just goes
that's not right even though that
motorcycles that little dirt bike didn't
weigh much that's
still 250 pounds yeah you have to like
take that into account it's like that's
250 pounds like the way that it moves is
not the way like it did a weightless
thing
they're not showing any inertia right
they're not showing the inertia
and it takes time to flick a bike over
into a new turn
you know what i mean it takes time for
that to happen and if you did do it that
fast then the motorcycle would
would would [ __ ] exceed the limit of
of of adhesion and
slam itself down on the floor yeah you
don't thought about
you can't flick over that fast and
violate if you did
you'd you you'd meet the limit of
adhesion the wheels that come off the
ground you just bam
yeah you'd high-side the motorcycle yeah
it's called you know
so no it wouldn't so i'm looking at that
i'm going that's not possible
yeah and then he he ranted up a wall
yeah that's not possible
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] how [ __ ]
springy your suspension
and it wasn't even a rounded wall it was
a straight wall
with stones yeah and i coulda swore i
saw him go up on that wall
i can't remember now and i was like whoa
i went whoa whoa whoa hey wait no
my brain didn't
that can't happen anyway well that's the
thing i feel like
you know in the quest to like make
really exciting action sequences
and you can do pretty much anything in a
computer nowadays so it's like they
don't think about
oh they all they think about is like is
this going to look cool yeah
is every bit is everybody can be like
hey that's not how that works yes and
how that works you see what
happened was he was riding on the ground
he went into a turn and then went up on
the wall
but it only looked possible because the
camera angle
made you think that that was down that's
not down yeah the force of gravity is
down
you can see you can't do that yeah dudes
would do it if you could
well yeah yeah dudes would do it
regularly but you can't do that well
yeah
zack said uh this is apropos nothing but
does your office have windows i don't
think i've ever seen any daylight in
there
yes there is a window right there yeah
it's just that i have like curtains over
them
because i don't want like a bunch of
like weird unauthorized light coming in
here
sometimes if the office door is open
there's actually a window right there
like right outside here it's like a long
window that goes all the way down and
that's where the cat tree is because
pookie is out there sleeping in her
little cat tree right now because she
likes to look out the window
at the birds and whatnot all right so
like i said gemini man we finally got
around to seeing it
um you know not a bad movie by any
stretch of the imagination
it was it was fun movie like i said i
know it kind of got
um you know as i didn't really see i saw
a couple of like really negative reviews
but most of them were just kind of like
meh
it's all right yeah well hey which is
what i thought
i thought it's all right we saw it for
free on uh
amazon amazon yeah you got amazon yeah
which like i said he just remembered i
paid four bucks to see it five bucks
probably yeah you wouldn't have felt
like you got ripped off
yeah you know what i mean it's it is
really weird when i looked up like
how long ago it came out that we didn't
go see it because at that point
we were going to see like most things
yeah
like actually we didn't see that one
because i remember like they showed the
trailer like a zillion times and then
we're just saying i want to see that one
maybe you just by the time it came out
you were like
[ __ ] that movie yeah maybe i don't know
maybe something else was on
yeah probably it was like probably some
other [ __ ] came out that we were like
more interested in seeing but yeah i
guess that'll uh
do it for our live stream today uh
today's wednesday right
i think so all right so we won't be back
enough for another live stream until
saturday but obviously there'll be
fun stuff going up tomorrow and going up
friday like usual
so anyway have a good rest of your day
wherever
you are whatever time it is where you
are and uh we'll see you guys again live
on saturday bye